beaucoup de cinéastes de l'ont rêvé
fantasmé cette fois ça y est pour la
première fois un film de fiction va être
tourné dans l'espace ici pas d'effets
spéciaux ni de décor lunaire le tournage
se passera là haut dans l' agence
spatiale internationale
[Musique]
l'espace objet de fantasme pour le
cinéma depuis plus d'un siècle en 1902
déjà le réalisateur georges méliès nous
emmener dans les étoiles avec son voyage
dans la lune un film de science fiction
le premier du genre truffé d'effets
spéciaux et tourné chez lui à montreuil
derrière ce mur en ruine à la place
occupée aujourd'hui par une scierie
c'est le vin en 1897 le premier studio
du monde le studio de georges méliès
après méliès le cosmos continue
d'occuper l'imaginaire des cinéastes
1968 c'est la sortie de 2001 l'odyssée
de l'espace de stanley kubrick gros
budget vaste décor sept mois de tournage
le film est un mélange d'anticipation et
de science fiction alors que l'homme n'a
pas encore posé le pied sur la lune
plusieurs années de tournage plusieurs
milliards de budget tout le monde sait
déjà que 2001 odyssée de l'espace et le
plus colossal film de science-fiction
jamais réalisé neuf ans plus tard c'est
au tour du réalisateur george lucas
d'être inspirée par une galaxie
lointaine très lointaine star wars en
1977 au casting de ce space opera mark
hamill carrie fisher ou encore harrison
ford encore inconnu à l'époque
c'est plus un film sur les princesses
sur les pirates de l'espace et les
mercenaires que sur la science c'est une
histoire aux dimensions humaines que les
spectateurs peuvent suivre après star
wars alien de ridley scott sorti en 1979
la science fiction et côtoie l'horreur
aux confins de l'espace embarquement
immédiat sur le tournage d'un film
devenu culte
les décors d' aliens sont parmi les plus
ingénieux jamais construit pour un film
de science fiction
le vaisseau abandonnait que les
astronautes vont découvrir sur la
planète sur laquelle ils se sont posés
est sans doute le plus étonnant du film
est l'un des plus impressionnants que
l'on n'ait jamais vu depuis metropolis
des années suivantes les films sur
l'espace deviennent de plus en plus
réalistes les effets spéciaux se
développe 2015 direction la planète
rouge avec le film seul sur mars
toujours de ridley scott pour rendre le
film encore plus crédible le réalisateur
a même collaboré avec la nasa ce n'est
pas de la science fiction c'est aussi
proche des faits que possible bébé notre
démarche c'était d'être dans la réalité
pas dans l'imagination aujourd'hui le
réel rattrape un peu plus l'imaginaire
après les russes un américain devrait
s'envoler lui aussi à bord de lier 16
pour tourner un film son nom tom cruise
l'acteur prendra place à bord d'une
capsule space x la date de tournage n'a
pas encore été annoncée
[Musique]